beautiful okay
so welcome to the seven secret patterns
view consultants don't want you to know
I am I am testing out a lot of these
patterns and part of it is I want to
know a little bit more about the
audience so I know how much detail I'm
going to go into for some of these
examples so raise your hand way up high
if you've been building view apps before
if you have prior experience building
view apps raise your hand up high if
you've heard of you never used it quite
a few people okay I'm sorry to say for
those of you who have never used view
before unfortunately some of this may be
a little bit over your head but I will
try to I hopefully that the previous
talk answered some of those questions
and you'll be able to use a lot of these
tips as soon as you start building view
apps and you'll be able to tell your
view using friends how you know more
about you than they do which will be a
lot of fun okay so first I want to talk
a little bit about me that's me right
there this is that the first view comps
in Poland that's me right next to Evan
who's actually wearing my shirt because
he forgot his view shirt amazingly and I
am the only person as you can see
looking at the wrong camera at the water
those looking in a completely different
direction I don't know what he's looking
at but I think I think this is a lot
about me everyone knew what camera to
look at except for me somehow and don't
know how that happened and I work on the
view core Docs I work on a lot of
tooling for developers in the view
community such as the the migration
helper I've developed the parts of the
EOS lint plug-in and I also do a lot of
consulting work helping companies all
around the world build mostly these days
view applications because when people
contact me it's usually because of you
and from this I've taken a lot of a lot
of experiences where I tell someone a
trick like something small that they can
do in their view apps and they think
like oh wow like I wish I knew this all
along I wish I you know this said this
had been more clear to me before and
sometimes it's not clear because we add
new things to the docs all the time and
we're also constantly updating them to
make them more clear and adding new
resources we're also developing a
cookbook where we hope to reveal some of
these patterns and I also have a
separate project where I've documented a
lot of these patterns and other patterns
that I don't have time to talk about
today but I will talk to you about the
the project later if you're interested
and I've divided these secrets into
three general categories productivity
boosts radical tweaks and unlocked
possibilities trying to stay with a
clickbait theme and I want you to know
even though there's gonna be a lot of
code here you don't have to take notes I
all of these slides will be available
afterwards I'm gonna show you a link and
I'm also going to show you some code
that's part of larger demos and that
code will also be available at that link
that you can check out later so
productivity boost number one smarter
Watchers how many people raise your hand
if you've used a pattern like this and
actually for those of you who haven't
used view before you can raise your hand
if you've used a pattern like this in
another framework where as soon as the
component is created you're doing
something for example maybe fetching a
user list from an API and then also
whenever some kind of data changes like
search text you're recalling that method
to fetch new data from the API for
example if that data that search text is
attached to maybe an input where as
users type you want to filter the users
and then make a new search and show them
a new list of users like if they search
for John show them the users that are
called John
so raise your hand high if you've used a
pattern like that in your app so quite a
few people this this kind of code looks
familiar so I'm gonna show you a few
optimizations that you can make to
improve this code a little bit and the
first one is that Watchers can actually
take a string as a value instead of a
function and that string is just the
name of the one method that you want to
call whenever that happens a lot of
people don't know that it's something
that's easy to miss it's a skip over in
the docs and there was once upon a time
when we didn't document it as clearly
which has now been fixed the other
optimization I want to talk to you about
is immediate true so I'm gonna rewind
you see we the value of search text the
search text watcher is a string now it's
an object and the handler is either the
function or the string that has the name
of the method that we want to call an
immediate true means we don't need the
created hook anymore because the handler
will be called as soon as the component
is ready it'll be called immediately so
this can not only make your code a
little bit cleaner but in case you
decide to do a greater variety of things
uncreated and also when that method is
watched by consolidating at all in the
watcher you can also reduce the surface
area for bugs in your application so
that's the first the first tip the first
of seven productivity boost number two
component registration so how many
people have seen a pattern something
like this in your apps where there are a
lot of like base components I gotta have
you raise your hands in a second - dorri
dorri I'm going to describe the pattern
first and then we're gonna do a raise
hands so you have a bunch of base
components that sometimes maybe just
wrap like another element in order to
apply some some styles to them that are
specific to your app so you're importing
face button bass icon bass input and
then you're registering all of them all
for sometimes less template code then
there is JavaScript code just to make
that possible
so now erase your hands how many people
have had a deal with something like that
before it feels like it feels kind of
frustrating doesn't it feels like how do
all this worry just just to get this
little bit of code I'm using the the
button in like every single component
why don't have to import it always I'm
going to show you a solution this will
look like a lot of code at first but I'm
going to walk through it slowly so the
require context down I I know I was told
a stay near the podium do you mind if I
okay I'm gonna jump up right here
require context that's something
specific to web pack that you can use
when you want to require a whole groups
of a whole group of components
programmatically so here you can see
we're requiring all of the components in
the current directory that matched the
pattern base - and end with dot view so
all the dot view components that start
with base - and base is a common prefix
that I like to use in applications for
components that I'm using everywhere and
they often just wrap an element and they
often have the name of the element in
the name like base input base button and
then we're going through all of the
components that match that pattern we're
getting the component config and then
we're getting a pass pascal case version
of that component and then we're
registering it right there at the bottom
with view dot component and this is a
global registration so that means it'll
be available everywhere in your app and
in order to use this you can drop this
code just in your in your main dot j s
or entry file for your application but i
often like to keep it in a component
slash underscore Global's is
and then in my main dot J's file or
entry file I'll import components slash
Global's so that all of these global
components are registered before my new
view instance and don't worry you don't
have to take pictures you don't take
pictures Lee there's gonna be slides
slides later so you can if you want I
guess you don't like live-tweeted but
maybe this isn't the most exciting
live-tweeting and i want to talk to you
about one more one more pattern here
that you might be interested in that's
actually not really so much of you thing
but more of a web pack thing that a lot
of people don't know so down here we
have component that default or component
config so how many people already know
like oh yeah I know why he's doing that
raise your hands it's like one person
two like two people who are like really
into web pack like maybe unhealthily
into web pack like me so if you in your
dot view component if you export default
that means your component options will
be under component config dot default
it'll be under the default option on the
exported module if you are importing
like if you import something from
something else
using the es6 syntax then that
automatically will look for a default
when you're using require though it
doesn't so we have to specify that we
want the default or if you've never
export defaulted in your view component
like let's say you're using module
exports equals for the common JSON tax
then your component options will be
under component config also if you are
if you just have like a template and
maybe some styles and you don't even
have a script tag then you are component
config will also be under component
config instead of dot default so little
little webpack thing
can trip people up a lot of times
they're not sure like why is it doing it
why is it a default sometimes why is it
not a default sometimes and I have been
one of those people and now I know and I
want you did not first be frustrated
with that too okay so now using that
pattern we can take all this javascript
that was needed to support this pretty
simple template and get rid of it we
never need it we only have to import
components when we actually need them
now you may be wondering like wow this
seems like why don't we just like import
everything globally like register all
components globally and and you could do
that but I wouldn't recommend it
for this reason for more niche
components like let's say you have a
navbar in your application and you
decide to stop using that navbar or
maybe you're not using that navbar for
all users or with webpack you want to
split it out into a separate module so
that it's it's only fetched from your
server when you actually need it to
reduce the size of bundles if you decide
to do something like that but you're
registering all of your components
globally then all of your components are
guaranteed to be in your bundle even if
they're not being used and even if you
have specified that you'd like to split
them out into a separate a separate
bundle so your bundles can get really
big and it can get difficult to maintain
over time but your base components are
being used everywhere productivity boost
number three module registration so this
is a little bit similar to the previous
one I want to get a quick quick hands
for people who have used view X before
okay and keep your hands up if you've
used view X modules okay
so view X modules are little pieces for
those who don't know little pieces of
state management that you can bring into
your application so like let's say you
might have an off module to handle
authentication in your app and keep keep
track of like whether a user is signed
in and things like that you might have a
post module to keep track of all the
posts that you know you're keeping track
of in your application that you maybe
you've fetched from the server and are
displaying to the user
same thing for comments for those posts
so these are just discrete pieces of
application state and this pattern isn't
unique to view acts if you're using you
know some other kind of library like
redux with view or if you're using a
completely different framework but are
using webpack you can still use a
pattern like this in your apps so
whenever you whenever you create a new
module whenever you have a new kind of
thing that you want to keep track of the
state for like let's say we also have us
you know post stars or you know maybe
users can star all sorts of things you
know so we we're keeping track of all
the things that users have starred in
the application we might have a separate
module for that and when we add that
module we'll have to add okay I import
stars from module stars and then also
add stars to the modules here it's a
little bit more setup that you have to
do every time and eventually your store
file here can get really big and busy
it's tedious but there's a solution this
might look familiar from what we
previously just did with component
registration so we are requiring all the
different modules I usually keep this in
an index J's file inside of modules by
the way all of the J's files inside of
the current folder and then we're going
through each of those files and if the
file name is indexed to J yes basically
if the
index touch es file is looking at itself
just like bail don't do anything with it
because it's the one thing in that
folder that won't be a module and then
we're getting the module name by camel
casing the file name and then we're
adding it to a modules hash our modules
object sorry I talked I was giving a
ruby talk earlier not exactly a talk but
sort of a consultant thing and then we
were requiring the module by its file
name and then we export all those
modules and there's one other
optimization that I want to show you
that I often like to do here if you like
named based modules or if you want to
set some other kind of default option
for all of your modules you can do that
here by saying like namespace to true
which is false by default for few X
modules and then add in the rest of the
the module options there that's really
great for managing its really great for
mentioning like best practices in your
apps like if you've decided on your team
like we want all of our modules we
namespace unless there's a very good
reason for them not to be named spaced
that's a great way to code it in so that
no one can accidentally leave that out
like they have to explicitly say names
based false so now our modules are our
store file is much simpler we can just
import modules from modules and an
export neat default new view X door
modules much better
so those were all the productivity
boosts now I'm gonna tell you about some
radical tweaks radical tweak number one
so these are these are tweaks that are
like tiny changes that have a big impact
cleaner views so how many people again I
want to I want to get a sense for how
many people have used view router okay
for those who haven't used view router
it's a companion library for view that
helps you manage pages with or sorry
helps you manage applications with
multiple pages so let's say you have you
know a forward slash it is just like
your home page and forward slash about
as soon as you need that forward slash
about if you're using a quote-unquote
single page application which is like
what everybody in industry calls it but
it's kind of a bad name because usually
single page applications have more than
one page it's just like one one HTML
file so this helps you have more than
one page despite that one HTML file that
you're serving to all your clients so
this is a lot of setup where in our data
we're setting some defaults and then
every time the route changes notice
we're watching it with our old watcher
trick or smarter watcher trick so this
is a combo trick we have to reset the
data to its initial value just in case
the previous route was using the same
component as this route so let's say for
example you're going from forward slash
posts forward slash one one being just
like the ID of the post and then you're
going from that route to forward slash
posts forward slash to what view will do
is it'll see like okay both of these
routes use the same component so instead
of you know starting it up from scratch
I'm gonna be a little bit smart and
render the minimal possible you know
make the minimal possible changes and
I'm not even gonna start like a new
host component I'm just going to give it
different data which can lead to some
edge cases which we have to deal with
with this code and sometimes it really
be nice if you could simplify to
something like this so as you can see
we've gotten rid of all of our reset
data gotten rid of our watcher now we're
just getting the post uncreated and we
have our get post method still and we
have our data that we only have to
initialize once which is ideal the way
to do that is with one line by adding a
key to router view and specifically a
key I often like to add is route full
path and that just tells view that if
the full path changes even if the
component is the same you should render
it from scratch so what that means is
you might have or you will have slightly
worse performance from route to route
but your view components or route
components will be a lot simpler and
probably less likely to have bugs in
them I've seen a lot of people get
frustrated from like oh yeah I guess we
can have like multiple posts and then
they they never test that until they
actually you know go from one post to
another they actually add a link from a
post page like a next post and then
there are wondering like what's going on
like it's still showing the old post and
they get really frustrated and this just
makes all of your routes a little bit
more predictable and they behave a
little bit more like views that you're
used to in a lot of other like back-end
frameworks especially if you're coming
from a back-end so I think it's more
than worth the sacrifice of slightly
slower performance on route changes for
most applications
radical tweak number two transparent
wrappers so we are looking at some like
base input base button components before
here's what are the template for our
base input might look like it just has
an input and then we're assigning the
value as the value value being passed
down as a prop and then every time
there's an input for those who aren't
familiar we were looking at V on earlier
in the first talked at is an alias for V
on and the colon is an alias for V bind
so whenever there's an input event
basically whenever you user type
something in it emits the input event to
the parent so this can work with V model
which we also saw earlier in the first
talked and you might also have some
Styles here too and then when you're
using this component it's very common
that you might want to listen for some
other kind of event that you haven't
explicitly specified in your component
so let's say every time the component
gains focus you want to do something and
you have to add this dot native modifier
because otherwise this will listen the @
focus will listen for a focus event
emitted from the component similar to
what we're doing with input here and the
dot native says no we want to listen to
an event that's on the the root element
of the component and the root element of
this component happens to be input
there's a problem
what happens when we add this what
happens when we refactor our base input
component in a little bit
now it's wrapped in a label and now the
root element of that component is a
label so our focus dot native listens
for a focus event on the label instead
of the input and so then you're focusing
on the input and wondering like why is
why isn't this working anymore I just
wanted to I just wanted to listen for a
focus event on the input it's a base
input event and this is my solution I
like to create a listeners computed
property that returns an object with all
the properties from listeners this dot
listeners stores all of all of the
listeners from the parent component and
then will override input so that again
it still works with fee model and then
we're going to use the V on object
syntax you can use V on without any kind
of event specified pass it in object and
it will listen for all of the the
listeners specified in that object which
means for our base input we no longer
have to do focus native we can basically
treat it as an actual input component
and just use focus unfocused do
something and it'll just work and it's
future proof when we're using this base
input component we no longer have to
know about like oh how is it structured
internally like what's the root element
this will just always work so I usually
recommend building base components like
this from the start but we're not quite
done yet there's an additional problem
what happens when we add this
placeholder here it'll add a placeholder
to the label because by default view
passes any and not
attributes any attributes not specified
as a prop to the root element of the
component in this case the label and a
placeholder on a label I you know I
actually haven't tried it but I would
assume it does nothing I would assume it
would just make my app not work when
really I want to pass I want to pass
anything here directly to the input
because I want it I want to act like I'm
just interacting with an input and
there's an option here to that's
relatively new to view if you learned a
few awhile ago and you haven't
completely reread the docs like every
week since then you might have missed
out in some things inherit actors false
this is an option that you can add to
your view component config that tells
view that you don't want this component
to just automatically inherit attributes
to the root element of the component
instead we're going to explicitly define
how these attributes are handled with V
bind actors V bind also takes an object
syntax and actors is an object that
contains all of the attributes all of
the attributes that aren't defined as
props in this component but passed to it
right here and I've seen a lot of UI
component libraries were before this was
available or maybe they didn't know this
was available they just had a huge huge
component file for like every possible
attribute that you could add including
like custom like data attributes from
some third-party plug-in that they want
to use with few like you know if they
they want to use like some like jQuery
date picker or something like that and
it requires like you know data a pic or
something like that and so this
component can sometimes become like
hundreds of lines long just with these
huge lists of attributes that we want to
make sure are passed to this input
component and this gets rid of all of
that
you never have to worry about whether
the attribute will be handled correctly
so now we really have fully transparent
wrapper components this is this is
actually one of my favorite tips once I
was able to do this like I I think there
might have been a tear there might have
been a small tear so we've gone through
the productivity boost we've gone
through the radical tweaks now we're on
to unlocked possibilities so these are
things that you might not even known you
could do with view number one single
root components so here's an error that
I've seen a lot where view tells me oh
you need exactly one root element how
many people have seen this before raise
your hand up high yeah I know this I
know this I wrote the doc that warns
people about this and it still happens
to be sometimes like I all right yeah
I'll just like I'll wrap it in a div and
then I'll make you happy
unfortunately that doesn't always work
sometimes you want a pattern that really
requires returning more than one
component like in this hypothetical
actually not that hypothetical because
this is an actual component I built
navbar component that renders you know
some persistent nav roads these are some
you know navigation routes that are
always there you know if there are some
some routes I only want to show if
you're logged in and some routes I only
want to show if you're logged out there
probably aren't a lot of applications
that have like sign-in and sign-out that
don't require like something like this
right this is a pretty common use case
but there's a problem here this
component this navbar component has a
single root element the UL but our
navbar routes
might be problematic because when we try
to do something like this it looks like
oh yeah we only have one root element
like Li we only have one Li it's just
repeated with V for a bunch of times so
we're trying to return an array of
elements and fuse not gonna be very
happy with us we've actually created an
error here how do you both run into that
yeah me too me too I still I still dream
sometimes well there's a solution a lot
of people don't know this but functional
components that user render function can
actually return in array of elements so
here we're rendering over or we're
mapping over all of our routes and then
we're returning an ally with a router
link which is a view router specific
component and that will actually work
multiple components I was really really
happy when I was able to do this too it
opened up like a whole new a whole new
arena for patterns the only downside
that I found is if you if you are using
components like this like all over your
app that means all the developers on
your team probably have to know how to
write render functions which is maybe
not something you might want if you have
a lot of juniors on the team or if you
have a just a really big team with a lot
of diverse skills so in those cases that
might be worth trying to refactor to use
something that's not quite as nice of a
pattern but still allows you to have one
one root at each component I'm curious
about this how many people hmm I don't
want to include the people who haven't
used view yet
you probably didn't know about this
trick but for the people who have used
view raise your hand if you didn't know
about this trick that render functions
could actually return multiple it's okay
so quite a few I'll be asking at the end
to see how many people didn't learn
anything and I will find you and I will
teach you something unlocked possibility
number two rendering non HTML so this is
a little map that I built with a library
called matte box GL which is a really
really cool mapping library that I
highly recommend these are all the
different cities that I've lived as you
might see you can zoom in zoom out you
can hover over cities and get a little
tooltip there's also a little navigation
down here and matte box GL as you might
have guessed from the name doesn't
render HTML but it actually renders
WebGL and that's how we get these like
really nice slick performant Maps and
WebGL code or matte box GL code tends to
look like this you know you have a map
unload you had a source at layers add
events now the only issue is this isn't
really like the declarative view code
that you may have grown to love this is
you know we're back to just declarative
code and I've seen I've seen
integrations like this where you
basically just have a component that's
like oh yeah I'm created just do all
this stuff and it renders the whole map
and and that component isn't really
reusable because if you want to have a
different map that's like slightly
different then it's still like one big
file and what do you do do you like copy
that over and then just like change the
one thing like oh we want to like
different colors we really want an API
it's more like this like we want to feel
like we're using HTML
so maybe a map box map and inside of the
map you're gonna have matte box markers
for all those little like pins that we
had in the map and I'm defining a
template here for what shows up when you
hover over that map in here matte box GL
actually allows us to use some excuse me
to use some HTML so we can pass it some
HTML in this template and then we have a
matte box navigation component to make
the the navigation show up and the way
that I like to do that is usually with
um this is the only time up like in this
kind of situation is the only time that
I'll say yeah might be okay to use this
stop parent everywhere else in the docs
and everywhere else in real life I'll
tell you know please don't use this stop
parent like it's for you know it very
specific situations and this is one of
those very specific situations where
inside of our map box marker components
and map Box navigation components it
might actually be okay to reach into the
parent and get the map because those are
very tightly coupled components you're
probably not going to have a map box
marker component that's not inside of a
map and if you want a little bit of a
different strategy so if you have deeply
nested deeply nested components inside
of the map box like if it gets really
complicated you might want to look into
the provide inject interface which is
also relatively new if you've been using
view for a while I'm not going to talk a
lot about that but you can check it out
of the docs just put that away provide
injector you can that's that's the one
case where you can write a little note
because that won't be anywhere and then
I'm created we do some initialization
before destroy we do some cleanup and
you can also with some Watchers you know
update your data source when you know
the the markers that are passed to maybe
this matte box markers components or the
items that are passed that's what the
prop is called pass to the matte box
markers component
Changez then you can watch that and then
instead of a template we have a render
function that just returns null you can
actually do that you can return null
it'll just like okay well I won't render
anything I try I'll trust you you got
this so these are really more abstract
components that allow us to take this
this imperative code these like lists of
instructions and sort of morph it into a
more declarative interface that is
reusable across your app and I want to
pay special attention to the the
template slot scope city here so you can
actually pass if you haven't used scope
slots before you can pass a template to
a child that uses data that only the
child has so for each city you know the
child is going to pass this part of the
template the city and then we're gonna
render the city name and an h3 and I
want to show you how we're actually
doing that in in MapBox GL so here we
have our scope slot and we're passing
marker dot properties to it this creates
some V nodes virtual nodes these are
like blueprints for HTML and then we're
creating a new view instance to render
the pop-up content nodes get the inner
HTML and then set that pop of HTML so
now we've turned view into sort of like
a generic template system you know sort
of like pug or you know handlebars or
something like that
ej s embedded javascript in HTML files
where you can you can pass it some data
and use it outside of you know the Dom
that view is controlling if you can't
get enough that was my last tip if you
can't get enough I recommend checking
out github.com slash crispy Fred / view
Enterprise boilerplate this is a Reis
release project that has a lot of these
patterns in it with like described in
detail in the source code including more
examples for like how to handle
authentication and apps and all sorts of
things I highly highly recommend it and
I also have an announcement just today
this is the first time announcing it
I just heard of the patreon ah small
plug I apologise patreon.com slash chris
view Fritz I just started this today
you're the first people in the world who
know about it because right now I use
like 20 percent view time and I have 80
percent consulting time now I want to
flip it so I can make your lives even
easier right more Docs more tooling
stuff like that and that's it that's the
end of the plug now we can do some
questions for just like a couple minutes
we might have time for one question you
can find these slides and other source
code at seven secret patterns I'm at
crispy frits everywhere github twitter I
think it's it actually but if I if I do
join another network that's who I'll be
repeat question for audience what does
it mean again repeat question for
audience oh god I got yeah yeah yeah I
know that deal okay cool cool cool cool
any questions yes that's right here yeah
you'll find a link to it yeah you'll
find a link to it yeah sorry the
question was do you have the map box
thank you I know seriously she just told
me
and then we clarified it okay yeah so
thank you thank you
ah where can you find the map box
project yes you can if you follow that
link it's in the readme there'll be a
link to it in the readme and it's not
actually like open-source it's sort of
just like a little demo because I took
it out of another app and it's not
really me it's not really built for
consumption for like other people yet
but you can do that if you want to and
you have more time than me go ahead
- number one most avoidable mistake well
I'd say if mostly if so many people are
making it it's obviously not the most
avoidable so I'm not exactly sure how to
answer that question gosh I do see I do
see a lot of people reach for like this
not parent or interact with the Dom
manually you know the win there when
they're not used to you know having view
mostly handle that stuff for them yeah
it's hard to say depending on their past
experience you'll get a lot of different
kinds of mistakes any other questions
yeah go ahead
most common anti-pattern that I've seen
let's see gosh uh there are some that
I'm torn because there are some that I
really don't like and there are some
that I've seen more unfortunately I
think we've done a good enough job in
documentation that the ones I really
don't like I tend not to see very often
but I I don't see this very often
anymore
cuz I've like plastered notices about it
everywhere but if when people are using
something like an event bus instead of
view acts or some kind of more robust
state management solution that can be
frustrating
I have zero minutes left so if you have
another question oh I can do one more
all right go ahead do I find myself
splitting up computed properties into
getting and setting a lot no I find
myself doing it sometimes but not
frequently yeah but some other people
like Guillaume from the view core team
he uses it more than me and I think the
way that he uses it like is cool and
good it's just there are often equally
good patterns that you could reach for
and that's one that I reached for a
little bit I don't know average okay and
I think that was the last question I
have time for but I will be here all day
so you're free to like ask me a question
during a break or just tell me about
like what you're building stuff like
that let me hear from you
ciao
you
[Applause]